♪ ♪
>> Bret: WELCOME BACK, JOINING
US TO TALK ABOUT CORONAVIRUS
RECOVERY, ALL THE LATEST NEWS,
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH McCONNELL FROM
CAPITOL HILL.
SENATOR, THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
>> GOOD EVENING.
>> Bret: YOU SPENT SOME TIME
ON THE SENATE FLOOR TODAY
LAMBASTING THE HOUSE SPEAKER’S
EFFORTS ON THIS LATEST
$3 TRILLION BILL AND WHAT’S
INSIDE IT.
I WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE
MESSAGING THAT YOU’RE SENDING
ABOUT PUMPING THE BRAKES ON A
PHASE FOUR AS OF YET.
YOU HAVE THE FED CHAIR, POWELL,
SAY THIS IS A FINANCIAL
SITUATION WITHOUT MODERN
PRECEDENT.
>> ADDITIONAL FISCAL SUPPORT
COULD BE COSTLY BUT WORTH IT IF
IT HELPS AVOID LONG-TERM DAMAGE
AND LEAVES US WITH A STRONGER
RECOVERY.
>> Bret: ESSENTIALLY SAYING
THAT LAWMAKERS MAY NEED TO DO
MORE.
HOW DO YOU RECONCILE THOSE TWO
THINGS?
>> EASILY.
I THINK THE CHAIRMAN OF THE FED
IS CORRECT AND WE DO ANTICIPATE
HAVING TO ACT AGAIN AT SOME
POINT.
I DO THINK IN TERMS OF TIMING
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE FED DIDN’T
SAY HOW QUICKLY, AND WE NEED TO
VERIFY HOW WE HAVE DONE SO FAR.
MAKE SURE WE KNOW WHATEVER
MISTAKES WE MADE WE DON’T WANT
TO REPEAT.
I AM CERTAINLY NOT RULING OUT
ANOTHER FISCAL PACKAGE AND I
WOULD SAY THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
FED AND I AND THE ADMINISTRATION
ARE NOT NECESSARILY IN DIFFERENT
PLACES.
>> Bret: YOU CALLED THE
SPEAKER’S EFFORTS JUST A
POLITICAL MARKER.
WHY NOT TAKE THAT AS THE FIRST
IN A FIRST SERVE AND VOLLEY BACK
AND FORTH AS YOU ALL HAVE DONE
BEFORE?
>> [LAUGHS]
WELL, IT’S AN 1800 PAGE LIBERAL
WISH LIST.
IT STRIKES ME IS HARDLY
SALVAGEABLE.
JUST TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF
SOME OF THE ABSURDITY, THERE IS
MONEY AND THEREFORE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
IT MENTIONS THE WORD CANNABIS OF
ALL THINGS.
68 TIMES MORE THAN THE WORD
JOBS, OR HIGHER OR -- ARE
MENTIONED IN THE ENTIRE BILL.
THE PARADE OF ABSURDITIES CAN
HARDLY BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
BRET, I THINK THE PRESIDENT AND
SENATE REPUBLICAN MAJORITIES
WILL BE ON THE SAME PAGE WHEN WE
GET TO THE POINT WHERE WE NEED
TO DO ANOTHER BILL.
OUR REDLINE IS GOING TO BE
LIABILITY PROTECTIONS FOR THOSE
WHO ARE BRAVE ENOUGH TO BEGIN TO
OPEN UP THE ECONOMY AGAIN IN THE
WAKE OF THE TRIAL LAWYERS WHO
ARE EXTENDING ALREADY.
HOSPITALS AND DOCTORS AND
BUSINESSES.
AS ABOUT OF A WEEK AND A HALF
AGO, 771 LAW LOSSES HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED.
WORKING ON NARROWLY CRAFTED
PROTECTIONS FROM LIABILITY FOR
THINGS DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
CORONAVIRUS, AND THAT WILL HAVE
TO BE A PART OF ANY PACKAGE.
IF WE ARE REALLY GOING TO GET
THE ECONOMY UP AND GOING, PEOPLE
HAVE TO BE BRAVE ENOUGH TO BEGIN
TO ENGAGE IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
I THOUGHT -- HOW ABOUT THE
PRESIDENTS OF UNIVERSITIES?
ARE THEY WILLING TO OPEN UP FOR
THE FALL?
OR ARE WE GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER.
MEDICAL TIME WERE NOT ONLY K-12
STUDENTS BUT POTENTIALLY COLLEGE
STUDENTS ARE STILL AT HOME?
ALL THOSE QUESTIONS NEED TO BE
ANSWERED BY THE FALL.
LIABILITY PROTECTION WILL HELP
PROVIDE THE ANSWER.
>> Bret: WHAT TRIGGERS THAT
NEGOTIATION START?
THE PPP, THE NEXT TRANCHE IS
GOING TO BE UP AT SOME POINT.
WHAT WILL TRIGGER THE ACTION OF
LEGISLATION?
>> PRESIDENT AND SENATE
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO BE ON
THE SAME PAGE.
WE WILL LET YOU KNOW WHEN WE
THINK THE TIME IS RIGHT TO BEGIN
TO MOVE AGAIN.
I THINK THERE’S A HIGH
LIKELIHOOD WE WILL DO ANOTHER
BILL, AND I’VE JUST INDICATED
WHAT WILL NEED TO BE PART OF ANY
BILL THAT ACTUALLY GETS A
PRESIDENTIAL SIGNATURE AND IS
BROUGHT UP AND PASSED BY A
REPUBLICAN MAJORITY IN THE
SENATE.
>> Bret: YOU SAID WAIT TO GET
WORD BUT IS WORD SOON?
>> LOOK, I THINK WE ARE ALL
TALKING ABOUT THIS.
I TALKED TO THE SECRETARY OF THE
TREASURY ABOUT IT YESTERDAY, TO
THE PRESIDENT’S CHIEF OF STAFF
AND TO THE PRESIDENT RECENTLY
ABOUT THIS.
I THINK WE ALL BELIEVE THAT
ANOTHER BILL PROBABLY IS GOING
TO BE NECESSARY.
BUT I’M NOT PREPARED TODAY TO
PUT A PRECISE DATE ON WHEN THAT
WILL BE.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU, AS I TOLD
YOU EARLIER, IT’S GOING TO
INCLUDE LIABILITY PROTECTIONS IN
ORDER TO GET THROUGH THE SENATE
AND IN ORDER TO BE SIGNED BY THE
PRESIDENT.
WE WILL LOOK AT WHAT THE
CONDITIONS ARE IN THE NEAR
FUTURE AND DECIDE HOW THAT OUGHT
TO BE CRAFTED.
IT’S NOT GOING TO BE A
$3 TRILLION LEFT-WING WISH LIST
LIKE THE SPEAKER IS APPARENTLY
GOING TO TRY TO JAM DOWN THE
THROATS OF HER MAJORITY.
>> Bret: YOU MENTIONED
SCHOOLS.
DO YOU THINK THE UNIVERSITY OF
LOUISVILLE SHOULD OPEN UP THIS
FALL?
>> I WANT THEM TO FEEL
COMFORTABLE TO BE ABLE TO OPEN
UP THIS FALL AND I THINK
ANSWERING THIS LIABILITY
QUESTION IS A BIG PART OF IT.
THE COUNTRY IS A YEARNING TO
BEGIN TO GET BACK TO NORMAL.
WE WANT TO DO IT CONSISTENT WITH
PHASE ONE AND TWO OF THE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION SET UP, THE
WHITE HOUSE TASK FORCE.
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE BELIEVE
THAT WE CAN BEGIN TO SAFELY
ENGAGE AGAIN, PRACTICING SOCIAL
DISTANCING, WEARING MASKS, WHICH
I HAD ON UNTIL I STOOD HERE IN
FRONT OF THE CAMERA.
WE ARE DOING THAT IN THE SENATE.
WE ARE UP AND RUNNING.
WE HAVE BEEN IN SESSION THE LAST
TWO WEEKS.
I’M NOT SURE WHERE THE HOUSES
BUT THEY ARE NOT HERE.
>> Bret: DID YOU GET DIFFERENT
MEDICAL ADVICE THAN THE HOUSE
DID?
>> WE ASKED THE CAPITAL
PHYSICIAN HOW WE COULD SAFELY
REENGAGE.
WE TOOK HIS ADVICE, AND WE ARE
PRACTICING IT.
WE ARE FOLLOWING THE ADVICE
WE’VE BEEN GIVEN.
>> Bret: HAVE YOU BEEN TESTED?
>> I VISITED THE WHITE HOUSE
LAST WEEK AND THE ANSWER TO THAT
IS YES.
>> Bret: DR. BRIGHT IS
TESTIFYING IN THE HOUSE TODAY
SAYING THE ADMINISTRATION WAS
WOEFULLY PREPARED, SAYS IT’S
STILL NOT PREPARED.
>> PLANS HAVE BEEN IN PLACE AND
IT’S DISAPPOINTING THAT THEY
WERE NOT PULLED DOWN IN JANUARY
OF THIS YEAR AND FOLLOWED.
THEY WERE NOT PUT ON THE TABLE
WITH A STRONG LEADER INDICATING
THESE WERE OUR PLANS, EVERYONE
FALL IN LINE AND FOLLOW THROUGH
WITH THE PLAN.
>> Bret: YOU SAID THAT THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION DIDN’T
LEAVE A PLAN.
THEY PUSHED BACK AGAINST THAT.
>> I WAS WRONG.
THEY DID LEAVE BEHIND A PLAN.
I CLEARLY MADE A MISTAKE IN THAT
REGARD.
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THE PLAN
WAS FOLLOWED AND WHO IS THE
CRITIC AND ALL THE REST, I DON’T
HAVE ANY OBSERVATION ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE I DON’T KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT THE DETAILS OF IT TO
COMMENT ON IT IN ANY DETAIL.
>> Bret: SENATOR BURR PULLED
HIMSELF OFF THE CHAIRMANSHIP OF
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
TODAY.
THERE IS AN INVESTIGATION, FBI
INVESTIGATION.
DIANE DIANNE FEINSTEIN BEING
INVESTIGATED FOR WHAT HER
HUSBAND DID WITH STOCKS.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT AND HAVE
YOU MADE A DECISION ABOUT
REPLACING SENATOR BURR AS CHAIR
OF THAT COMMITTEE?
>> CHAIRMAN BERGER AND I HAD A
CHANCE TO TALK ABOUT THAT THIS
MORNING.
I THINK HE DID THE RIGHT THING.
FOR THE COMMITTEE AND FOR OUR
REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE.
I THANK HIM FOR DOING THAT.
AT SOME POINT OBVIOUSLY I’LL BE
NAMING A NEW CHAIR.
>> Bret: SENATOR RUBIO,
SENATOR RICH?
>> I WILL BE NAMING A NEW CHAIR
SOMETIME SOON.
>> Bret: OKAY.
LET ME GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
MICHAEL FLYNN SITUATION IN THE
NEWS ABOUT THIS UNMASKING.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT AND IS IT
IMPORTANT IN YOUR MIND?
>> IF THERE WERE IN FACT
MISBEHAVIOR SURROUNDING THE
FLYNN CASE, THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
NEEDS TO KNOW.
CLEARLY THAT WAS THE VIEW OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
I GATHER IT’S NOW IN A RATHER
UNUSUAL PROCEDURE BEING REVIEWED
BY THE DISTRICT JUDGE BEFORE
WHOM THE CASE WAS.
I THINK WE ARE ANXIOUS TO GET
THE FACTS.
WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED?
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC NEEDS TO
KNOW, ALL OF US WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW.
ONE THING ABOUT WASHINGTON, YOU
GUYS ARE SO GOOD AT YOUR JOB,
TRUTH ALWAYS COMES OUT.
SOMETIMES IT TAKES A LITTLE
LONGER THAN OTHER TIMES.
WE WILL FIND OUT WHAT IN FACT
DID HAPPEN.
>> Bret: I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THE ELECTION.
YOU CALLED IT A CHALLENGING
ENVIRONMENT.
ON A SCALE OF 1 TO 10, 10 BEING
THE MOST CONFIDENT, WHERE DO YOU
THINK REPUBLICANS ARE AT HOLDING
THE SENATE?
TO GO I’M NEVER TOTALLY
CONFIDENT IN ANY RACE BUT I CAN
SAY WITH REGARD TO THIS
QUESTION, I HAVE SAID THE SAME
THING FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE
CYCLE.
WE HAVE 23 MEMBERS.
A REALLY BIG GLASS AND THE
REASON WE HAVE A REALLY BIG
GLASS IS THIS IS THE CLASS THAT
TOOK OUR MAJORITY BACK IN 2014.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE UP.
23 UP.
DEMOCRATS ONLY HAVE 12.
THIS WAS A CHALLENGING CYCLE
FROM THE BEGINNING TO THE MIDDLE
NOW.
I THINK THE MAJORITY IN THE
SENATE IS VERY MUCH IN QUESTION,
AS IT HAS BEEN FOR A YEAR AND A
HALF.
>> Bret: ARE YOU TRYING TO GET
SECRETARY OF STATE POMPEO TO RUN
IN KANSAS?
>> THAT HAS BEEN MY HELP.
YOU CAN SEE HOW WELL I HAVE DONE
SO FAR.
[LAUGHS]
>> Bret: ARE YOU STILL HOPEFUL
ON THAT FRONT?
>> THE FILING DEADLINE IS
JUNE 1, SO THIS IS BEN’S WON’T
LAST MUCH LONGER.
>> Bret: WHAT DO YOU TELL
VULNERABLE REPUBLICANS IN TOUGH
RACES?
WHETHER THEY SHOULD BE EMBRACING
THE PRESIDENT FULLY OR PROVIDING
SOME DISTANCE FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
DO YOU THINK HE WILL BE A
REFERENDUM ABOUT HOW THIS
ADMINISTRATION HANDLES THE
HEALTH CRISIS AND THE ECONOMIC
CRISIS?
>> LOOK, EVERY STATE IS
DIFFERENT AND FAR BE IT FOR ME
TO GIVE ADVICE TO A CANDIDATE IN
MONTANA VERSUS COLORADO VERSUS
MAINE.
I THINK EACH OF OUR CANDIDATES
ARE VERY SHARP.
THEY GOT ELECTED SIX YEARS AGO.
THEY KNOW THEIR STATE’S BEST,
AND I DON’T HAVE ANY KIND OF
UNIVERSAL RECOMMENDATION ABOUT
HOW TO RUN IN A GIVEN STATE.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK THERE
WILL BE AN IN PERSON REPUBLICAN
CONVENTION?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
THAT’S A VERY INTERESTING
QUESTION.
I THINK THAT IS THE CURRENT
GAME PLAN, BUT I THINK WE HAVE
TO SEE WHAT THE STATUS OF THE
PANDEMIC IS IN LATE SUMMER AND
MAKE THE CALL THEN.
>> Bret: WHAT IS YOUR BIGGEST
WORRY RIGHT NOW?
>> RIGHT NOW?
GETTING THE ECONOMY OPEN,
GETTING THIS CORONAVIRUS
BEGINNING TO RECEDE IN ALL PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY, AND HELPING
AMERICANS STAGE A COMEBACK.
WE HAD A FABULOUS ECONOMY AS
LATE AS FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR,
AND WE LIKE FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO BEGIN TO BENEFIT FROM
A COMEBACK AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
LOOK, WE CAN’T BORROW ENOUGH
MONEY TO PROP THIS ECONOMY UP
INDEFINITELY.
WE HAVE TO BEGIN TO ENGAGE THE
ECONOMY AGAIN.
I AM CONVINCED THAT WE CAN DO
THAT SAFELY.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT TWEETED
OUT THAT HE THINKS
PRESIDENT OBAMA SHOULD BE CALLED
UP TO A HEARING IN THE SENATE.
HE CALLS IT OBAMAGATE.
>> OBAMAGATE, IT’S BEEN GOING ON
FOR A LONG TIME.
GOING ON FROM BEFORE I GOT
ELECTED AND IT’S A DISGRACE.
>> Bret: DO YOU CALL IT THAT
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT
CALL TO HAVE THEM TESTIFY?
>> IT WILL BE UP TO CHAIRMAN
GRAHAM TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
I THINK HE MAY HAVE ADDRESSED IT
ALREADY.
I’M NOT CERTAIN.
>> Bret: HE SAID HE WOULD BE
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH IT AND IT
LIKELY WOULDN’T HAPPEN.
WHERE DO YOU THINK THIS
INVESTIGATION GOES?
>> LOOK, THAT’S UP TO CHAIRMAN
GRAHAM TO DETERMINE HOW TO
HANDLE IT.
I HAVE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE IN
HIM AND HE KNOWS WHAT HE’S DOING
AND I’M GOING TO FOLLOW HIS
LEAD.
>> Bret: FINALLY, IF YOU’RE
TALKING TO SOMEBODY IN KENTUCKY,
YOU’RE UP FOR REELECTION AS WELL
WELL.
WHAT DO YOU TELL THEM THIS RACE
IS ABOUT?
>> WELL, IN THE KENTUCKY RACE,
IT’S A LITTLE DIFFERENT FROM
OTHERS.
WHAT I TELL MY CONSTITUENCIES
I’M 1 OF 4 CONGRESSIONAL
LEADERS.
I AM THE ONLY ONE NOT FROM
CALIFORNIA OR NEW YORK AND THAT
I AM UNIQUELY SITUATED TO LOOK
OUT FOR MIDDLE AMERICA AND IN
PARTICULAR KENTUCKY.
SO CONSISTENT WITH MY
RESPONSIBILITIES AS MAJORITY
LEADER, I TRY TO DO THE BEST I
CAN FOR KENTUCKY.
I THINK IT’S BEEN A REAL BENEFIT
TO OUR STATE TO HAVE THE
MAJORITY LEADER OF THE SENATE